you don't we were talking earlier
obviously you're smoking you don't if
you ever [ __ ] with the shrooms
I'm really scared but I want to but I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it what are you
scared of
I don't wanna I don't want to see the
wrong thing or think I see the wrong
thing you'll never see the wrong thing
now the thing you see everybody need to
see
you might not like what you see but you
need to see it
mushrooms like psychedelics they'll like
they'll give you what you like with what
you need even if you don't know that you
need it does that make sense
they're scared they can be scary yeah
you know what's scary is have you ever
heard of DMT what about it have you
heard of it oh no that's [ __ ] crazy
you smoke DMT you go away for 15 minutes
that
can you do it I don't even drink liquor
wine I don't drink [ __ ] but
codeine marijuana coating the marijuana
pills
do you feel like
um
do you feel like you're addicted to
codeine because that's a hard thing I
don't feel like I know it oh that's fair
have you ever tried to stop and like you
go through withdrawals and [ __ ]
why I try to stop when I know I'm gonna
go back I just keep this [ __ ] real with
myself
it ain't like got a hold of me or
nothing but I mean yeah you don't like
what I like you're also not like uh you
know there's people who do lean and you
can tell because they're [ __ ] they
look pregnant you're at least still in
good shape you know yeah I know I take
care of myself yeah that lean got some
[ __ ] man
that [ __ ] is wild all my homies who
sibling they might be [ __ ] legit in
shape everywhere but that belly that
[ __ ] is
that [ __ ] is serious man I'm still
active
I ain't gonna let it get like this I
ain't gonna see it is it is it still is
it still hard to like get a
uh the uh actual activist or is it man
if a [ __ ] say that drinking act they
lying cause that shit's like gone right
[ __ ] being gone that's what I'm saying
yeah
yeah if you buy some activists you
better [ __ ] die or something they're
gonna die yeah he said you're gonna die
you're gonna die drinking a fake [ __ ]
trying to be cool that's crazy